hey what's going on its bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday April 4th 2016 how's it going
how are ya I am in Ottawa Canada right
now Oh Canada it's [ __ ] freezing here
every time I come I nostril stick
together yeah like we came we did
[ __ ] I almost said Wichita I don't
want the [ __ ] in place Windsor we did
Windsor me mercy and [ __ ] Joey be Joe
Bartnik we did Windsor the first day not
even know what day that is you had
Friday we did it on Friday and I brought
this little [ __ ] [ __ ] coat you know
Nia calls it the Kleenex coat it's just
too saline all those little ones been
born in the 70s when they had the big
puffy coats
well they still making the puffy coats
then that just like they're like little
ones you know what I mean
they look like little uh you know like
you're you're a rib Shak and you open
the little thing and then give you a
little moist little towel it looks like
there's a bunch of those sewn into the
coat you know the thing you know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about well as
though North North Face numbers so I got
that in a hoodie because I looked at the
[ __ ] forecast and it said that you
know it's gonna be like 50 degrees and
that Coach good down to 40 so I thought
I was fine and I was fine I was snug
like a little bug in a rug for the first
was it two days when I was at the second
day oh the second day I was at Casino
Rama that's right that's when I started
the snow and that's when I started
questioning like my jacket game is the
young kids say my jacket game was not on
point however
by the way I didn't bring any much
bucket broadcast equipment because you
know this trip is a [ __ ] all
right this is one of these it's known in
my businesses of thrash all right
sometimes you go on the road it's a
[ __ ] cakewalk all right whatever the
[ __ ] that means
what is a cakewalk I know I've never
even looked at up is there a certain
kind of way you'll walk when you're
[ __ ] carrying a cake maybe that's
what it is
sorry if I'm [ __ ] the levels are too
high you're just trying to talk down my
recorder like a microphone that's gonna
be my guess I said when you have a
[ __ ] cake you know if you have a cake
he gonna be walking a little gingerly no
offense to me right so you walk a little
lightly with it maybe you know you're
walking like you're walking like Paul
virzi when he puts on his [ __ ] Jordan
force for the first time you should have
seen him walking down a casino
he was walking like on his heels because
he didn't want to crease them I got to
tell you something I don't [ __ ]
understand people who [ __ ] stand in
line and then stab each other over a
[ __ ] pair of sneakers I just really
do did you see that God didn't you
Jordan threes around dude that [ __ ]
crazy
the new Jordan trees are [ __ ] crazy I
swear to god they don't look like nurse
shoes to make big stupid bulky looking
[ __ ] things I think I have a pair of
Jordan ones I like the colors I never
liked those [ __ ] things either when
they came out and they were red and
black I thought those were the ugliest
[ __ ] things ever I told you before
I'm part of the back in the day
I like those Bruce Jenner Decathlon
shoes you know this simple pair with
[ __ ] three stripes on the side I was
cool with sneakers right through towards
the end of the 80s when they started
having like the [ __ ] bo Jackson
the neon Deon [ __ ] remember that neon
green and neon pink those [ __ ]
sunglasses the second it went into that
[ __ ] those pastel colors and the stupid
[ __ ]
Bogg pump Oh maybe if I put some more
air in my sneakers I won't have white
guy legs the Reebok pumps were whereas
stupid is Batman vs Superman they're
alright okay surely but here we go this
cakewalk surely you've heard the term
cakewalk did somebody write a whole
[ __ ] article on this
good lord cut to the [ __ ] chase
alright I'll read this as fast as I can
surely you've heard the term cakewalk
used to describe some sort of challenge
or task that is reckoned to be pitifully
easy surely you have you stopped saying
that stop calling me Shirley Shirley you
have please please don't lie
good lord who [ __ ] wrote this the
figurative definition has been around
since the early 19th century as long as
the literal one in fact it appeared in
print but did you know that the term is
actually pretty racist racist racist
racist I'll bet you didn't what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this idiot who this is
such a classic you know if you actually
had to get a real job writing you
wouldn't have won you know everybody on
the internet fancies themselves like
there's some sort of journalist you know
when they're writing this is just no you
just [ __ ] write not a would it's like
acting in a web series in you're upset
you didn't get nominated for a [ __ ]
Oscar
nor did I okay did you know it was
pretty racist I'll bet you didn't what
because you don't know some [ __ ] and
that means everybody else doesn't you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean I didn't know it but I'm a [ __ ]
I really don't like this person
he said nor did I okay that's the first
humble thing this person said maybe he
can come around maybe I was wrong I
still don't think I could drive
cross-country with this person nor did I
until I looked into the origin of the
term and found out it had roots in the I
don't know how to say this word
antebellum south of the early 19th
century can you just tell me what the
[ __ ] it means
I would started during this era of
firmly entrenched slavery in the States
the cakewalk was a dance event where
slaves were invited to dress up in the
fine clothes and took on the heirs of
the white aristocracy oh so this is like
when the Wayans brothers did white
chicks what do they do is this like the
first Def Jam comedy they started doing
the white guy voice I said get out in
the field to do the work that I should
be done and everybody starts flipping
out dying laughing
the next slave coming to the stage
alright they were held in the plantation
home in the same rooms where the
resplendent balls were held among white
society oh my god how much do those
people [ __ ] stink back then putting
on all those extra layers of clothes no
such thing as deodorant right destroying
you that's one of those things where you
washed yourself in the same [ __ ]
trough the goddamn horses drank out of
the cake walk was similar it was a ball
held for the slaves Oh so this is their
Christmas party I didn't know they did
that I didn't see that in roots you know
wasn't all bad every once in a while
they had like a company party after 364
and a half days it's absolute horror
then they would they let him in the
house yeah sorry about all that other
[ __ ] would you like some pumpernickel
the wife just made it well let's get him
out of the house they seem to be a
little restless I'm [ __ ] nuts
Oh what an ugly period the cake like you
know like it's not an ugly period now
but you know it's less ugly alright
let's continue okay the cakewalk was
similar it was a bald ball held for the
slaves couples promoted prom innate
sorry through the ballroom bowing deeply
and frequently chins and noses held
highly aloft if you got to tell me they
finally gave him a [ __ ] party and
they still were [ __ ] about it the
couple who perform the best
interpretation of how the white folks
did it
cake baked one imagines by a slave
I didn't imagine that stop putting words
in my mouth I would figure the white
people after all that [ __ ] time baby I
mean you know what I consider we ruined
their [ __ ] lives I think we can make
him a cake once a year but we're only
giving it to one of them Jesus Christ
time you think you found the depths of
how evil that [ __ ] was you find another
layer true oh my god another layer just
like a cake Jesus I'm an artist this
morning
all right the cake walk looks similar
but it was also very different its
intent was to emulate white society in
order to mock it only Jesus there's a
dangerous [ __ ] game yeah I told you
this is like the first Def Jam comedy in
much the same way as Jesus Christ
Saturnalia the ancient Rome winter
solstice festival oh yeah exactly what's
in the same [ __ ] way where the rules
of social order were turned upside down
and the slaves and laborers became the
rulers and Matt and masters attended
attend their servants oh they did this
in Rome this is just all [ __ ] weird
can you imagine the tension during that
so then the Masters [ __ ] tended to
the slaves and you know the slaves
wanted to be just as [ __ ] me but then
they were like well we got to kind of
alligator on this ship as it goes back
to the regular way tomorrow and then I
would think the master be like all right
you want me to wade into that sea of
hatred towards me not to keep an eye on
me please stay tight okay why it's still
the left side of my nose that means I'm
fearing for my life the slaves involved
did indeed mock the ridiculously refined
customs of the aristocracy yes and they
surely meant it but during the cakewalk
they were allowed to mock them and by
ruling over even the very event that
should under my
his authority the plantation owners
managed to assert his authority you know
something I was in such a [ __ ] good
mood I hate this [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] cakewalk well you know
what I already clicked up so how does
that mean it's easy what does that mean
it's it's a cheap laughs you know what I
got to go back I just closed the [ __ ]
window I got to go back so how the [ __ ]
did that become that does not sound easy
to make being a slave all year and
they're doing one you get to do one
[ __ ] day we get to make fun of this
the master it's not a cakewalk that's
[ __ ] difficult right all right as if
its roots in slavery don't make the
cakewalk racially charged enough it
transitioned in the minstrel show how
did it transition into being something
easy of the Jim Crow era or even or even
worse
gone was even the power a lot of to the
slaves to buy the market just of the
original cakewalk in stage reproductions
of balls of the balls white performers
in blackface performed as blacks who
made sincere clumsy attempts at
emulating whites out of a desire to be
like them not to undermine them oh okay
and then it became that I still don't
understand why it's easy
the original cakewalk walks being local
affairs held a you know what [ __ ] the
[ __ ] Internet all right can I
fast-forward to this
Oh God he used the word apparently
there's no other word alternative comics
like to use more than that apparently
all right clumsy attempts to apply the
original kick walks with being local
affairs held in the confines of the
southern plantation the minstrel shows
traveling as a matter of course it was
later interpretations they became
defined the concept in the rest of the
country in the world and what he could
describe perhaps is the deep desire to
stop being so incredibly racist American
society as a whole abandoned the racial
basis of the cakewalk in favor of its
simply describing something so easy that
just walking could yield the reward of a
cake there it is
the definition is still vaguely racist
it isn't racist if you think the
definition means it's going to be easy
you're not even being remotely vaguely
racist you just don't know the history
right you know Jesus Christ alright well
there's that was [ __ ] depressing well
fortunately I'm up here in Canada where
you know they have all the angelic white
people according to Michael Moore you
know up here they're all a bunch of
angels and nobody has to lock their
doors which of course we don't know it's
true generally speaking people don't get
a lot of one another all right so that
was an excruciating 15 minutes I don't
know how you guys enjoyed it
so anyways kind of [ __ ] did I get onto
that [ __ ]
oh because yeah I thought the whole I
thought the I thought this whole trip
was gonna be a muffin dance how about
that can I say something like that I
thought was gonna be a little muffin
dance did you know that the origins of
muffin did you actually are pro domestic
violence I bet you didn't surely you've
heard the term muffin dance before
please please please don't tell me you
have not
the origin of muffin dance comes from
the early 1900s when women when they ask
can we vote to were forced to show their
clams and dance out of the voting booths
as people through desserts at them this
became known as the muffin dance because
clamp indicated that their [ __ ] stunk
and turned men off later in 1929 the
great great grandson of Abraham Lincoln
said I cannot tell a lie some of these
[ __ ] clams do stink but there's no
reason to make them do a muffin dance
they should be allowed to vote too and
all the guys said yeah you know what
you're right and everybody had muffins
so next time you use the term muffin
dance just know that you're being
vaguely sexist all right I'm sorry why
am I doing this why am I talking like
this why why am I sitting here in this
[ __ ] freezing cold hotel room I can't
find where the [ __ ] heat is I'm
saying and one of these red rum which is
one of those you know I like old [ __ ] to
a point you know
I like I thought I like to have having
an old house until I [ __ ] had to deal
with all the [ __ ] I had one in her
old house old hotels I kind of like I
love the lobbies but the second you
[ __ ] go up to your room you start
walking down the hall you know you feel
like you should be riding a big wheel
and you're gonna come around the corner
and those two creepy [ __ ] chicks are
gonna be standing there god damnit that
[ __ ] movie freaked me out
that movie still got it's still
disturbing that's just a disturbing
[ __ ] movie you know and it's not the
fact that he goes completely [ __ ]
insane it's just as a comedian watching
a man suffering through writer's block
like that and having that woman coming
up whose face is shaped like a [ __ ]
parking meter asking you how it's going
every [ __ ] 20 minutes I love how they
blame the [ __ ] hotel
rather than that you know what I would
say she means wealth you know they just
were a bad couple I think that that's
what it wasn't when they went down in
society they could go to events and they
could sort of water down their awful
relationship by interacting with others
and then once they just got you know
once they would just stay in there at
the [ __ ] hotel you know for the whole
goddamn winter I don't understand why
they had to be there to watch it get out
I mean like what do you what are you
gonna be doing up there I mean no it's
um the level with which that it's gonna
[ __ ] snow no [ __ ] he's gonna go up
there and vandalize the place if they
come there it's because they need
shelter it was really no reason for it
you know and I was also a vaguely racist
movie wasn't it you know saying reverse
racist at white people will be like oh
yeah oh the [ __ ] snows fifty feet in
the [ __ ] air oh yeah I got to write a
book yeah why don't I [ __ ] go up
there
y'all hang out there and I'll do my own
room service every [ __ ] day I'll stay
in room [ __ ] two 706 and everyday
I'll take a [ __ ] elevator all the way
downstairs to the kitchen
how who the [ __ ] would sign up for that
really didn't have any sympathy for you
no I'm just [ __ ] with you I think
it's a great movie I'm just in a grumpy
goddamn move because today I got a drive
from [ __ ] Ottawa all the way up to
Sudbury and then right after the show I
got a my travels all [ __ ] up I got dry
over - [ __ ] it Detroit which was like a
[ __ ] eight-hour drive you know takes
me back to the days when I was doing
college gigs and I remember one time I
had this gig in the Upper Peninsula of
Michigan right some [ __ ] town up
there that began with an H alright so
like an [ __ ] I'm like alright I'm in
Michigan and I didn't look on the map
to see where uh to see where you know
basically the [ __ ] college was at and
I just I just flew right into [ __ ]
Detroit and then I realized that the
Upper Peninsula as actually it's sort of
you know it's the dick of Wisconsin
I should have flown into [ __ ]
Milwaukee and driven up but I didn't I
flew into Detroit and I had to go drive
all the way all up the whole [ __ ]
state it was pretty cool cuz I got to
drive over there whatever bridge that is
the Mackinac Bridge and whatever the
[ __ ] it is I'm trying to look it up
right now but I can't remember the name
of the [ __ ] I think it was Marquette
I always started beginning with an H
maybe I was thinking Lake Huron I think
it was in Marquette I did a [ __ ] gig
up there yeah and I had like a I forget
what time my flight was but I had to
basically it was an early morning flight
in Detroit it was like a [ __ ] eight
hour drive or some [ __ ] seven-hour drive
and the show didn't start till 9:00
I was done at 10 o'clock and I had like
a 6 or 7 a.m. flight I can't remember I
just I was just like you know I could
night everybody and I jumped in my
[ __ ] car and just drove like a
[ __ ] lunatic after her already having
done the drive drove all the way back
just like nodding off almost falling
asleep is one of dumbest things I ever
did just trying to save like the [ __ ]
50 dollar change fee or some [ __ ] like
that so you would think that I would
learn from that not old freckles but
this time we actually have I got like
Barnett conversion to help me with the
[ __ ] drive oh my god dude Sudbury is
yeah it's as high up is [ __ ] the
Upper Peninsula Michigan what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] for some reason I go and yeah
there's no really no airports around
here I don't know why we didn't just
take a couple of puddle jumpers there I
have no [ __ ] no I know why I know why
initially I was picking up a rental car
in Detroit
I was gonna drive this whole thing and
then at the last second they're like you
know it's a pretty long [ __ ] Drive so
I said alright well we'll fly most of it
and then we'll do the thing you know
then we'll get the rental car we get the
rental car and [ __ ] Ottawa blah blah
blah would do it one way but then I was
still leaving out of Detroit this is so
[ __ ] stupid oh this is gonna suck but
anyways what will be cools tonight I'm
playing a small like hockey arena and
it's gonna be great that's gonna be
[ __ ] good time I played one of those
last night here in Ottawa you know
whatever the [ __ ] it was called Oh
anyways this is what the [ __ ] I wanted
to talk about something else I want I
want to talk about I got read the
[ __ ] advertising here I know this
podcast is all over the place okay
I can't say it's a [ __ ] cake walk
anymore can't say a cake walk anymore
because now I know it's [ __ ] racist
alright well actually I can't say it to
you guys but I could say it somewhere
else
you know it was kidding you I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say it cuz I've been
saying it my whole [ __ ] life you know
it's just gonna cut Nets that's how you
but that's how you become an old person
where someone's going like grandpa do
you know the origin of that oh shut up
your first year of freshmen all right
you [ __ ] concept been around 80 years
stop breaking my balls if I want to say
23 spear god dammit I'm gonna say you
know you know but you almost kill your
[ __ ] grandfather trying to get him to
stop saying something alright let me let
me get to the advertising here oh here
we go the old trunk club
trunk club everybody do you hate going
to the mall sure we all do you surely
you've been to a mall surely you're not
going to sit there and say you haven't
trunk club shopping takes forever
and no one has time for it well people
who enjoy it though they live for it
let's go shopping
you know those [ __ ] dopes but just go
down and they will sit there and look at
outfits you know never once putting
their ear up to the shirt and hearing
the crying child that's sewed it
together you know throwing out their old
[ __ ] clothes
just end up in the ocean or in some
hipsters back who pretends he had the
job you had right shopping you know I
still we drop off clothes at Goodwill
who's kidding who I still do and I
thought it went to [ __ ] homeless
people and it doesn't it just goes right
on their racks and they turn around they
sell which makes me feel good knowing
that they don't end up in a goddamn
ocean right anyways and now it's spring
so you need pastel polos and boat shoes
right and it'd be nice to have your own
personal stylist too I think that has to
be a joke nobody needs pastel polos and
boat shoes I think that those should
only be for the upper 1% of this country
you know what I mean it's for the robber
barons and their date rapists children
you know and they can walk around in
what would be great is you're making
exclusive for them so they'll feel like
oh look at us we are cut above it'll be
like a status symbol oh really what it
is is it's a warning for anyone that
dates their children you know what I
mean it was said I have a wearing the
Scarlet a the Euro [ __ ] you just have
those pastel colors just be like you
know it gives it gives the ladies a
little heads-up you know that there's
going to be a sense of entitlement
coming at them with a hard-on right you
got to give them the [ __ ] heads up
Jesus Christ I'm just trying to do my
part here right let me pour out a little
wine cooler for Edith Wharton here and
it'd be nice to have your own personal
stylist too with trunk club you don't
ever have to set a foot in a store and
you get your very own stylist for free
make it easy to look your best and
clothes that fit you perfectly
handpicked by your own personal stylist
for free with trunk club go to trunk
club.com / / typing your measurements
share your likes and dislikes and you
get your very own personal stylist you
know they'll pick your clothes from
Oakland oh my god this is a muffin dance
right here they'll pick your clothes
from over 80 top brands and ship them
right to you
you keep what you like and you send back
what you don't in the trunk trunk club
you know they're gonna [ __ ] send
these clothes to some maniac okay some
serial killer because you know they
don't like to go to malls either unless
they're trolling for victims right and
what's gonna happen is they're gonna get
confused and they're gonna go you know
you know which is the [ __ ] the I
don't like this shirt trunk in which is
the one there's stuff in the body and
they're gonna [ __ ] throw a bunch of
shirts in the bottom of a lake and
they're gonna send a body back to trunk
club I'm calling that right now calling
that right now then they're gonna do a
first 48 about it but when this truck
showed up they couldn't understand why
this shirt smelled so bad I'm sorry
that's bad trunk club is not just
another way to shop online
it isn't your stylist takes the time to
understand your you your unique look if
you live in there's something funny
about that was just picturing somebody
standing in a mirror looking at
themselves trying to figure out their
look you know you know that little thing
we have your hands on your hip and then
you stick one foot in front of the other
like you're a horse answering a question
because you want some oats and if you
live in Dallas New York Los Angeles
Chicago DC you can stop by one of the
trunk club club houses to work with your
stylist in person for free now wait a
minute I thought the whole point was not
to go to a [ __ ] store trunk club is
not a subscription service there's no
monthly fee this is what I like here
your stylist is free shipping is always
free and you have ten days to try to try
on the clothes risk-free what are you
putting it off like a term paper I'm
gonna try that shirt make a statement at
the next big event on your calendar with
the look that's hand-picked just for you
and your style Mike what are you trying
to say I'm trying to say I'm at a rape
colors get started at trunk club today
free mucus expert advice no work thanks
to your very own personal stylist at
trunk club get started today at trunk
club
/ / that's trunk club.com / / excuse me
trunk club.com / / sorry my voice is a
lot out of it I've been screaming my
jokes for three nights in a row oh god
am I really going to start a sing right
now [ __ ] okay but Oh doo doo me undies
me undies no more sweaty balls boo doo
doo doo me undies me undies skating down
the [ __ ] canals you're in [ __ ]
Ottawa you're on the canal you're
wearing your undies with your pal both
your balls are really [ __ ] dry in
fact they're getting really chafed
because it's called yummie undies we'll
keep them warm all right me undies by
the way if you ever skate the canal out
of here I've always been afraid to do it
you know I've done it but I was nervous
when I did it I just kept thinking about
the omen like I was gonna fall through
and everyone's gonna be hacking at the
ice trying to get me out again the
canals only a foot deep you know it's
really no big deal so the worst thing
that could happen is you could get
severe frostbite they have to remove
both your feet like in now that movie
misery long in the movie she just
[ __ ] breaks his ankles and the book
she cuts off his [ __ ] feet I love
when they do [ __ ] like that it's just
like okay so you've severed a major
artery and this guy somehow doesn't
bleed out in the bed cuz let me guess
you tied your [ __ ] belt around his
calf does that even work by the way if
somebody [ __ ] did you see the [ __ ]
redneck that blew his goddamn leg off oh
my god
there's this new [ __ ] thing that
rednecks are doing you know because they
just love shooting stuff and blowing
stuff up and as much as people you know
who don't have their own spread living
in the middle of nowhere
judge them somewhere in the back of your
head you know it's fun you know riding
around on a [ __ ] four-wheeler
shooting a gun on your own [ __ ]
property you know it's gotta feel great
that's a level of freedom that I I've
never heard I've never felt you know I
live in the city where there's noise
ordinance
you know which basically noise on my
property should not carry over like you
could basically call the cops if
somebody splashed around their pool too
loud he's mocking the fact I don't have
one the cops go over there you just
start beating people right or air-quote
getting the situation under control
not Christ what the [ __ ] was I just
talking about oh yeah riding around you
know so I watch this this new thing that
they do they take this some sort of
explosives and they put it in these old
cars and then hopefully they stand far
enough away and the [ __ ] thing blows
up well this [ __ ] guy
all right redneck blows look at this
[ __ ] right here goes redneck blows
himself up blows up house blows himself
up in a bonfire blows up pigs almost
blows his head off this is such redneck
stuff stupid redneck blows himself up
fire blows up blows himself up boat
motor blows up [ __ ] rednecks it crazy
blows leg off let's see where is it come
on all right yep and an American gun
enthusiast I'll he had to throw American
in there American Georgia man loses leg
ever explosives filled lawn mower I will
link you this you don't see his leg blow
off but you blow blow off his body but
you this guy basically it's called I
hope I say it right tanner right it's
some sort of explosive and the new thing
that these rednecks do is they [ __ ]
he [ __ ] you know you put it in
whatever vehicle you notice it's really
what's going on here is these rednecks
are starting to be a little more classy
you know after all these [ __ ] years
of you know having a car die they just
leave it on their front
now they're getting rid of it they're
blowing them up so they put this
tannerite however the [ __ ] you say this
is explosive and there's some sort of
formula like basically forever for every
such and such amount you need to be like
a hundred feet back all right so let's
say whatever when it will just say this
guy's if he's got a handful of this
[ __ ] tanner out God we're doing math
now pill all right and he basically
needed to be about like I don't know 500
feet back and he was 40 feet away from
this lawnmower and he [ __ ] shoots
this [ __ ] right he [ __ ] shoots it and
he blows the [ __ ] thing up right [ __ ]
yeah somebody had to do their [ __ ] DJ
remix of it anyways he's shooting it and
he's shooting the lawn motional son a
[ __ ] blows up and then he's on the
ground and you see it you just you can't
see anything you just the cameras
pointing at the ground he just here we
go I'm amazed that he could actually say
that I would just be staring it to stop
going I mean well I like he's got to
tell that story for us at what point
does that can he laugh along with
everybody else you know I bet he's
considered like a tragic a tragic figure
now in the redneck community you know
like he'll probably you know at the next
cross-burning they let him light it he
hobbles up and everybody gives him a
round of applause like they're all
[ __ ] said like what happened to him
was some sort of a terrorist act rather
than self-imposed [ __ ] stupidity
Jesus Christ you know I feel bad for the
guy but who the [ __ ] are you doing
shooting a goddamn gun at dynamite
basically whatever the [ __ ] it is in a
goddamn lawnmower that the [ __ ] blade
alone the shrapnel from that
but I gotta look this [ __ ] up top 10
dumb ways to blow you up to die alright
listen we'll go with that to die all
right well you lay here your March
Madness brackets top 10 dumb ways to die
[Music]
there's always the opening the elevated
doors before the elevator gets there not
looking and then stepping in falling to
your death playing with guns and I don't
[ __ ] know our top 10 dumbest ways to
die here we go
alright starving in a supermarket I
didn't want to read that one diving off
a cliff but survived but died of shock
from the high price of your hospital
bill oh Jesus Christ Jesus I don't need
to hacky jokes I have plenty of those
come on ten absolute dumbest ways to die
all right enough of this is all gonna be
clickbait horseshit okay you know what
go [ __ ] yourself you guys should be
dying right now waiting for me to read
this trying to kiss a reflection of the
moon in a lake all right somebody died
doing that then I got to click another
page you know what I mean what seeking
of advertising on every [ __ ] page and
somehow you can [ __ ] afford Twinkies
this month go [ __ ] yourself
all right so anyways let's talk about
the notorious oh the first the first day
we were in Windsor right across from
Detroit and it was awesome I upstate
this great hotel and you could look
right across the whatever the [ __ ] it
was I guess it isn't Lake Erie isn't it
just a river I don't know what the [ __ ]
you call it is it a sound of the Detroit
River and you see beautiful downtown
Detroit Detroit never looks more
beautiful when you're not in Detroit
when you across the [ __ ] river
looking at it from wins
and I just kept asking a bunch of people
like cuz I'm going to invest I want to
buy something in Detroit I'm gonna do it
goddamn it you know invest back in
America I think I totally believe in
that city I know it's gonna come back
and I was asking people where to [ __ ]
invest and they were just all laugh and
you're like about forty miles north like
nobody believes in it which is what's
making me want to [ __ ] buy their even
more you know it's [ __ ] dirt goddamn
cheap it's got to come back at some
point it has to come back sit right
there on the river I know the [ __ ]
Cleveland Cavaliers guy bought up a
bunch of [ __ ] skyscrapers there
that's got it you know he put like the
people from Google and one of them I had
no idea but the [ __ ] is so cheap there I
don't I don't get how you [ __ ] loose
and I like the idea you go in there
right you fixed the [ __ ] place up
that you buy and then you don't kick the
people out there living there and then
they got a nice place to live right
maybe that gets them in a better mood
slowly but surely you just start turning
it around I think any American right
what we should do with these [ __ ]
cities because God knows the
government's not going to do anything I
don't think they can't because they're
[ __ ] to the [ __ ] Federal Reserve
bankers all right I don't have any
[ __ ] money
they're robbing Peter to pay Paul so I
think with whatever money they let us
keep we ought to just start [ __ ] you
know buying up some [ __ ] in Detroit turn
it around don't kick the people up get
it going again maybe then they can start
making American cars right again and
start [ __ ] with the BMWs the Audi's
and it's a [ __ ] travesty that we
don't really have anything they can [ __ ]
with those cars the fact that they're
going to alligator on the base level
Cadillac the base level Lincoln
Continental all right are gonna pale in
comparison to what those maniacs in
Germany are doing I mean I don't
understand what you know you know we can
[ __ ] do it
I guess Buicks are selling like [ __ ]
hotcakes
is that a racist is a racist thing
anyway cakes it out I think his racist
odd cakes back in the day when they were
actually
every 10 years let a slave have a
birthday one of the things the slave
owners would do was actually heat up the
cake so we would burn it burned their
mouth because they were that evil here's
another chapter of white evil that you
didn't know existed selling like
hotcakes I guess hot cakes were pancakes
back in the day and you know goddamn
well you know having pancakes must have
been a [ __ ] treat because I remember
back anyway and when you read the time
saw your book right uncle Barry Finn
he's [ __ ] kids paint the fence just to
get an apple like that was considered
like a treat here's all day long you
were just sittin around eatin [ __ ] I
don't know she went on shrubs I don't
like the [ __ ] Authority so anyways I
want to buy there man I want to buy
something there and not become the
[ __ ] evil person that boots the people
out that are in there he just fixed the
[ __ ] place up gives a [ __ ] you know
once of course the people in there then
[ __ ] the whole place up then I would be
upset yeah how much that plaster cause
it was trying to do something nice
whatever eventually I'm gonna look into
that so we did whit Windsor and we had a
great time and Rosie was there so of
course I smoked a cigar so you know you
know I only do two cigars a month now so
last month I only smoked one February I
had two and a half because we started to
smoke one and it wasn't smoking well I
may have got halfway through and like
this [ __ ] cigar sucks so I actually
smoked two and a half so I smoked two in
January and I flicked the [ __ ] Rain
Man right now so then four and a half
five and a half so I'm actually half a
cigar under my goal for this year so
April first ice already smoked a cigar
so now I can only have one more or
technically one and a half more but I'm
actually gonna try to get down to one a
month and to be honest with you I kind
of like to go all the way to my birthday
in June and not smoke another one right
god damn and I enjoy him i jus i enjoy
the [ __ ] lifestyle i joy a whole
[ __ ] thing about it I love going in
I love picking them out I love the
excitement I love the smell I love the
old [ __ ] chairs you sit there I love
that there's no [ __ ] young people
there you know and by young people I
mean anybody 39 and younger you just
don't run into him you know everybody's
just chilling the [ __ ] out smoking a
cigar I don't care what kind of a maniac
you are all these [ __ ] kids that they
put on ritalin and all this type of [ __ ]
you just give these kids a cigar Sam sit
down puffs you know Lexi you know you
you just you're thinking about it just
think about how great life is there's
some pot smoking cigar that's all you
just not thinking out and how great it
is I'm great it is you can enjoy the
[ __ ] day you start planning your
retirement how the [ __ ] you gonna get
out of this [ __ ] so you can just sit
around in whatever Zen you've somehow
coming to I mean I swear to God if
cigarettes make you feel like that I
understand why people do that [ __ ] it's
funny but you know non-smokers like
myself you know I actually am a smoker
down with the [ __ ] cigars but you
know he's always looked down on those
[ __ ] people that smoke cigarettes
they were huddled outside and all that
[ __ ] you know I don't know maybe maybe
maybe they know something I don't I'm
not advocating smoking I don't know what
I'm saying
by the way Canada wins their Airport
Jesus Christ what a [ __ ] gem that is
I love small airports there's nothing
better than that little ass [ __ ]
Airport then when I went to Toronto we
flew into we flew over the propeller
plane Jesus Christ if you saw Rosie walk
into that he's one of those guys I don't
I don't look if he sees propellers he
feels like he's riding in like a Model T
Ford you know I always just say to
myself oh it's a it's gonna fly better
well we have much less of a chance
because there's less working parts here
for something to go bad you know I don't
know that's what I tell myself so
anyways we went to Toronto we didn't fly
into their nightmare [ __ ] Airport we
flew to the Toronto Islands which I had
never heard of is a [ __ ] little ass
Airport there
we get picked up and we took a little
ferry you know it's [ __ ] hilarious
across the Western Channel it literally
like we started to go and I started
videotaping it and by the time I panned
from out my side window to the front
window we had already gotten across it
you get across it in like 30 seconds or
they have a tunnel you can walk
underneath the Western channel I did
that on the way back it was a nice
little ass Airport after all these years
of traveling I love a little mom-and-pop
Airport get in get the [ __ ] out it's
hilarious you show up they still have
the old school metal detectors so you
don't have to go through that [ __ ]
radiation shower that for some reason I
just don't understand that so to stop
terrorism you're gonna give all of your
countrymen cancer well if we [ __ ]
kill everybody who they gonna blow up so
so anyway some flour into this [ __ ] it
down for 24 minutes um anyways but these
shows cannot it cannot have been going
any better and I've been working my ass
off in Los Angeles for a reason that I'm
not allowed to say yet for whatever
[ __ ] reason so I've been worried that
I can't you know I can't [ __ ] do
stand-up as much as I'd like but us I've
been doing a bunch of spots like little
10-minute spots trying to stay shap
I just do a little bit of my act even
the jokes I hate I'm like yeah I just
[ __ ] say it so you remember how it
goes and I cannot be having more fun up
here man just having a [ __ ] great
time just figuring out my act I even
figured out this new way to trash women
that like isn't his [ __ ] mean as I
used to do it but I still get to make
the same point so I just don't come up
you know is a complete [ __ ] lunatic
all the time and I don't want to be that
guy you know what I mean as much you
know something I realize I never
finished reading the me undies think
that I you know okay whether you're
wearing a suit or sweats you spend
almost 24 hours a day and your underwear
but instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights
his everyday clothes your underwear is
probably boring the undies about to
change that oh yeah they're about ready
to take your balls to the next level
then hang a little disco ball you know
it's called the third eye the third ball
right now if you're [ __ ] nuts you
know can you imagine her excited face
when she sees a disco ball hanging off
the end of your dick all right should
probably get that checked please include
all of the following no mo Modell is
pronounced modal every pair of me undies
is made from sustainable source modal
Modell a fabric that's twice as soft as
cotton
nothing can describe the fit and feel of
me undies but once you try them on you
understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear then
if you don't love your first pair of me
undies they're free no questions asked
me undies has dozens of styles and
limited edition prints to help you make
a statement with your underwear whether
anyone can see them or not remember
Superman I don't like that joke remember
Superman what that he's fighting Batman
you know somebody on WorldStarHipHop
when one of my favorite [ __ ] websites
you know watching people the funny vines
you know music that I I'm completely not
even aware of I get to learn about that
[ __ ] and then just some of the most
[ __ ] insane fights you're ever gonna
see and there's always a tipping point
when you watch fights on worldstar it's
just always the amazement and then
somewhere it just starts to become sad
if you just start thinking what is wrong
with human beings why do we do this [ __ ]
why can't we just go out to a [ __ ]
McDonald's or a [ __ ] dance club you
know and not have like a 5150 fight I do
have to tell you the respect I have for
someone that actually would go into one
of those modern-day Braveheart [ __ ]
things I mean I don't give a [ __ ] how
many martial arts classes you've taken
in your life there is nothing that they
teach you in those [ __ ] classes other
than to turn around and run which you
already know how to do
when you get in the middle of a [ __ ]
melee like that it's just inevitable the
[ __ ] odds you know that's the fight
version of being like the helicopter
gunner in Vietnam where they had like a
[ __ ] a life expectancy of two [ __ ]
weeks it's just you just stand-in there
and you know what's gonna happen and all
right you're gonna keep gonna
something's gonna [ __ ] hit you you
got to get knocked out and I have to
tell you the influence of MMA on these
[ __ ] street fights now back in the
day I seem to remember when you knock
somebody out that was it
you didn't sit on their chest and throw
another 40 punches to their head waiting
for Big John to come over and [ __ ]
you know uh sure you out of there
there's no ref that [ __ ] [ __ ] we
already knocked somebody out then you
boot him in the head I mean at that
point that's like attempted murder man
you won you knocked them out you come up
and you do this you sit on that chest
and do a [ __ ] speed bag thing [ __ ]
brutal but anyways you know these me
undies I'm gonna get through this
shipping is free in the US and Canada
and you save up to eight dollars a pair
with me undies subscription plan I get
the subscription you know it's like a
[ __ ] endzone dance I always thought
it was cooler when you [ __ ] just
scored a touchdown you flip the ball to
the ref it like yeah I'm gonna be doing
this all day if you knock somebody yeah
yeah he just turned around like yeah my
job's done here you walk away like Clint
Eastwood in one of those drifter movies
you know you sit on that Chestatee like
you [ __ ] just kind of spaz out
screaming what did I tell you [ __ ] you
know with your voice goes up 9 octaves
when your voice goes up like 9 octaves
like that you kind of betray your
badassness he kind of yeah he can hear a
level of excitement like oh my god I
can't believe I won that's what I always
hear having said that I would want to
fight anybody in those videos
and it's not even the fact that I know I
would lose I just know that after I was
knocked out you do irreparable [ __ ] I
can't me say the word brain damage which
is unnecessary [ __ ] brain damage you
knocked me out you want I'm laying there
okay
my hands are pointing out into outer
space I'm knocked out you know why do
you got to go there and knock my melon
around more if I was running for
president I would bring that up I see in
America that goes back to when you knock
somebody out you walk away like Clint
Eastwood in a spaghetti western
all right shipping is free in the US and
Canada and you can save up to $8 a pair
with me undies subscription plan get the
subscription or a single pair get 20%
off your first order when you go to me
undies comm / / that's me a nice calm /
fur for 20% off your first order me a
nice calm / / alright Dollar Shave Club
everybody Jesus Christ I got to mourning
these [ __ ] things Dollar Shave Club
everybody Dawg shake Lancome is a
special offer for new members who joined
today you'll get a free month of the
executive razor when you buy a tube of
dr. cha vcz shave but I'm saying coffees
alright cuz that's how I've been saying
you know it's Carver's I like saying
coffees and I'm a big fan of Dana Carvey
alright so there you go this is the
first time they've ever done something
like this and once you try
dollarshaveclub.com you'll become a
proud member like millions of others one
reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what the greedy razor
corporations charged that means when you
join Dollar Shave Club you can afford to
shave with a fresh blade anytime you
want which feels fantastic you'll get a
free first class no wait you've got a
first class shave when you use the
executive blade without hurting your
wallet what is the executive blade
another reason is there dr. CAV easy
easy shave butter using it with the
executive makes the blade glide gently
for the smoothest shave ever dr.
Carver's shave butter isn't your average
shave cream it's a unique conditioning
formula with high-quality natural
ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth
and right now new members who buy a tube
of the shape bata get the executive
razor for free you know what they've
never done anything like this before so
take advantage of it before they come to
their senses and it's only available by
going to dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / high dollar
shave club calm / alright
stamps.com everybody trip said that this
is the last one
mercifully alright stamps.com trips to
the post office are never convenient
well if you don't like your wife that
[ __ ] great you know what I'm gonna
walk so why not get posted right from
your desk with stamps calm stance calm
even gives you special postage discounts
you can't get at the post office
including first-class Priority Mail
express international and more you'll
never pay full price for postage again
here's how stamps calm works using your
own computer and printer buying print
official US postage for any package or
letter then just hand your mail to the
mailman or mail lady or drop it in the
mailbox it's that easy
no wonder over 600,000 small businesses
are already using stamps calm I use
stamps calm whenever I send out one of
my [ __ ] posters you know it's funny I
have a poster for this this tour the
plowing ahead tour and it was an old
Telly Savalas movie poster right and you
know I spent all this money having this
guy dude the whole thing up and we had
the whole [ __ ] tag line on it you
know it looks like an action movie like
I'm sitting there but he was telling
Savalas was holding the gun I'm holding
a microphone
we both have bald-headed right and he
had a casino wallet should I have like a
helicopter and all his dumb [ __ ] that
I'm [ __ ] into so it looks like this
action movie then we had all this
[ __ ] just read you know silly [ __ ]
like they tried internet porn they
fished out the oceans but nothing could
stop the man with no answers right and
it was like this coming you know
supposed to be like this movie poster so
I don't think the casinos understood it
they took away all of the the words
whatever the
you call it all the text they took all
of it away and they just have this
standalone poster and now I just look
like a magician like is he gonna come in
in a helicopter and make a truck
disappear like it doesn't make any sense
and I spent all this [ __ ] money on it
and most of them are just using my
poster for my last tour you know when I
had with what's left of my hair grown
out and a beard so I don't even look the
same it's just it's just been a [ __ ]
show anyways right now
sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name bar for this special offer for week
trial plus $110 bonus that includes
postage and a digital scale call to
action verbatim reduce your bait him
don't wait get started with stamps calm
today go to stamps calm before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in burr
that stamps comm enter burr be you are
are they ago was that verbatim enough
I'm such a control freak I can't even
handle people who are giving me money
telling me what the [ __ ] to do 55
minutes alright this whole day's getting
away from me I have even read any of the
[ __ ] questions I haven't even talked
about the Bruins how were one point out
we beat st. Louis and then we lost to
Chicago of course didn't see any games
because I was [ __ ] traveling you know
it's funny I had like five or six kunti
Chicago fans talking [ __ ] you know it's
so funny the last time we play and we
beat them I don't talk any [ __ ] do I
talk any [ __ ] no right I hate these
[ __ ] people like these these
whack-a-mole fans that you know we
kicked your Rose today then they duck
back down no where to be found
you know when you [ __ ] lose like
Chicago's got to do in the playoffs you
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] I actually liked
the Blackhawks and fans like that make
me [ __ ] Rudy root against them so
anyways coming up this week my Bruins my
beloved Bruins all right we are playing
our next game is where the [ __ ] is and I
think we're playing to know we play
Carolina I believe
I think we play Carolina next right I
get the schedule right here where is the
schedule all right we play Carolina on
Tuesday it's at the TD Banknorth [ __ ]
the Home Depot Garden whatever the [ __ ]
they call it the Carolina and
notoriously plays uh stuff they've
always match up well it's always a tough
game and then we have Detroit which is
huge their one point against ahead of us
on Thursday and then our last game is
against Ottawa on Saturday all right so
basically the two teams in front of us
are Detroit and Philly both one point
ahead of us I believe so the great thing
is during this week Detroit and Philly
play each other so no I think Philly's a
few points ahead so I I'm just rooting
from Philly to just win the rest of the
way out all right
III at this point I have to root against
Detroit I don't have anything against
Detroit other than their [ __ ] [ __ ]
offense and they really are [ __ ] offense
you know what I mean the funny thing
about them is they don't realize that
their run is over and that it's now all
about Chicago and LA and they're wearing
the crown you know what I mean for some
reason Detroit is still living off
[ __ ] Yzerman you know I guess they
won one last decade to PI Oh actually
they went to yeah but you can just see
you can see it in Detroit it's over you
know something that I'm gonna experience
when Brady and Belichick are gone and
I'm gonna be like yeah I've a way the
Patriots it's like yeah but their God
yeah yeah they're we're in the same
uniform but it's not the same I'm
[ __ ] with you I actually love Detroit
I love the franchise I don't like the
offense you know and I've never been
that way as I like to think with all the
success that I know I only talk [ __ ] if
people give me [ __ ] that's how I try to
be you know I don't try to act like
because my teams are successful that
means somehow in my own personal life
I'm a success like some people do those
you know I'm really judging all
Blackhawks and Redwing fans by half a
dozen people which isn't fair so you
know what good luck to all you and I
hope the Bruins spark and pull it out
and if we
don't we got no one to blame but
ourselves just [ __ ] good lord what a
[ __ ] season up down up down up down
up down that's what the [ __ ] it's been
and I just need up for the last two
three up just [ __ ] nice three-game
winning streak and no one will remember
any of this [ __ ] Dan Shaughnessy is
sitting there with the [ __ ] hard-on
being like I can finally write an
article about hockey that I understand
somebody blew it oh yeah I can write
this all [ __ ] day alright let's get
to the questions then I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here alright
the All Star Cafe on March 28th podcast
you briefly mentioned you were regular
muncher and Nia was a waitress
the Allstate not the all-star but some
reason he won't all start up here then
Allstate before she got pink-slipped
and now and now and they now closed down
Allstate cafe on the Upper West Side
I thought your listeners might be
intrigued to learn that your meeting
place was also a meeting place for a
young teacher and her murderer in
January of 1973 during a one-night stand
murdering a partner guarantees there
ain't no second night right Jesus Christ
I didn't know that the grotesque multi
stabbing crime got so much infamous
publicity that the pub changed its name
from the WM tweeds to the Allstate the
murder inspired the book and subsequent
movie starring the then scantily clad
Diane Keaton also apparently Kevin Bacon
had once tended bar there too I wonder
if they fired him also I didn't know
that Jesus that's [ __ ] creepy I don't
believe in ghosts or anything like that
not even remotely but that type of [ __ ]
is just scary by the way I love hearing
about history even as much as I [ __ ]
that cakewalk thing I was trashing that
guy I like that type of [ __ ] all right
girlfriend bothered an annoyed by sexy
TV show character dear Billy Blank ball
soon
my girlfriend and I were recently
watching the new season of daredevil and
we're enjoying it however one character
Elektra was introduced and she bothered
the hell out of my girlfriend for
reference Elektra is this character that
is sexy provocative and an all-around
badass ninja woman Elektra is also like
that weird sort of isn't that that
mythology thing what is the what is that
weird [ __ ] thing isn't that what I'm
not even going to say because if I'm
wrong as to do it was some sort of
creepy sexual relationship within the
family doesn't it
you know daughter/father and then the
other one is son mother where the son
kills the dad or some [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] weird when I see those types of
stories actually start believing in Adam
and Eve well yeah there was just two
people and they banged and then they had
this incestuous [ __ ] horseshit for a
couple of generations until we [ __ ]
ourselves on maybe that did up and maybe
that's why Neanderthals and all like or
whatever they are the original caveman
their heads are all [ __ ] up looking
it's because everyone was related who
the [ __ ] knows anyways she was a cool
character but my girlfriend hated her I
noticed that it wasn't anything against
the character since she couldn't tell me
why she didn't like her other than she
just bothers her other people have told
me that their girlfriends slash wives
are the same way with Elektra when
watching this show with their
significant other I know it isn't just
this character because any female that
is in a sexy badass role I have noticed
women specifically ones with boyfriends
don't like is this just some kind of
insecurity women have do they really
dislike their boyfriends seeing someone
that may be sexier than them well yeah
if you [ __ ] put it that way they're
gonna be annoyed hey honey
you know I see that girl look how much
sexier she is than him when she watched
his Fight Club you know does she say how
[ __ ] much better of old Brad Pitt's
looking anyways are they worried that
this fictional TV character is going
steal me away from her I am wondering if
I should say anything because quite
frankly it's starting to get on my
nerves
she will root against the character for
no reasons besides the ones listed above
I don't know if I would just make her
moot make her more pissed off though
have you ever been in a situation like
this love the show and as always go [ __ ]
yourself here's the thing one of the
worst things you can do when you get
into a relationship with the woman is to
start having your behavior be dictated
by just trying to keep them in a good
mood all right I'm not saying walk
around to be an [ __ ] but if you're
not being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and they're
just being moody [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you got to call him out on it yeah like
it and and this is nothing to you got to
treat him like adults rather than
treating them like children which is
what a lot of guys do because physically
we're stronger than them so you feel
like if you say anything to him it's
like you're yelling at a child you're
not not only is that an adult in a lot
of ways they're more advanced because
they can't beat the [ __ ] out of you they
have to go they have to go with their
mental alright that's why they can just
manipulate you like a [ __ ] little
puppet there because they can just play
Jedi mind games because they're not
gonna they from day one they're like
alright this [ __ ] thing is gonna be
stronger than me at some point so I need
to learn how to control it just using my
brain right that's how you end end up
holding [ __ ] yarn O's kidding whoo no
woman shows anymore right they barely
even cook that's how you end up at
[ __ ] brunch this is what you got to
say you're just gonna just hit pause and
just I would just be like what is your
problem with this character you're
ruining this show for me okay if I look
at daredevil he's got abs you see me
acting like a [ __ ] baby about this
you know if you don't like the way you
look go to the gym pitiful once you be
inspired by this [ __ ] day that's that's
what I feel when i when i watch a
superhero movie other than i the other
other than like a when the [ __ ] is this
dumb horseshit going to be over it
always makes me feel like you know i
hit the gym I could literally sit there
and watch Thor who's probably a foot
taller than me a thousand times better
looking that I'm ever gonna be and all
that dude does is make me want to go to
the gym but then again if you look at
our roles like all I need to do is earn
enough money where I can get a Ferrari
and a toupee and next thing you know I
can bang some [ __ ] that's been in a
[ __ ] magazine and that's basically
how it works if I Drive the car in the
right part of the world right drive
around the [ __ ] French Riviera Jesus
Christ you have no idea what you're
gonna be banging they don't have that
option you know what I mean they can't
be like well I'm a six but you know if I
I start making money I can go get myself
a Brad Pitt you can't and you know what
you can't blame society you got to blame
the good Lord for that one so maybe
that's why maybe that's why because no
matter what she does she can't I don't
know I don't [ __ ] know ask her but
you know something I wouldn't be on you
know she's ruining your show you got to
call her out on it all right okay going
bald dear Billy bald cap I'm 24 and I'm
going bald this runs in my family as
both my grandfather's were bald so I
don't have any sort of identity crisis
about it in fact I'm leaning into it and
will joke about it when appropriate my
question to you is when do I finally
start buzzing my ever buzzing everything
away the last thing I want to do is rock
at George Costanza Costanza look but
would like to have a full head of hair
while I can before I look like I'm in
denial
no comb-overs for this [ __ ] my hair is
thin but still covers everything on top
though my barber did crack more jokes
than usual at my last at my expense last
time I went to get a cut no I didn't
provide a picture because this isn't a
[ __ ] Rogaine commercial given your
experience I'd love to hear your input
on what when you pulled the trigger to
buzz it all all the way and possibly the
input of the lovely Nia well Jesus
Christ what am I your [ __ ] stylist
well I think you know something if your
barber starts making jokes you know what
I mean I feel like there's not enough
time
on the clock for you to make a comeback
that's basically like now you're lining
up and the dude across to you is talking
[ __ ] about how they're moving on to the
next round of the playoffs and you're
not so it sounds like it's already over
you know I don't know dude why and what
am i what kind of a [ __ ] man asks
another man a question like this just
[ __ ] you know shave your [ __ ] head
I'll go get a hair plugs we'll put row
gate on it or diet a different [ __ ]
cup I don't give a [ __ ] what you do with
it what is my experience my experience
was when I was just sick of it I was
sick of the slow death and I was just
like you know what let's just put this
thing out of its misery and I got to
tell you it's not nearly as bad as
everybody [ __ ] thanks kid to
everybody would love to have a full head
of hair but you know something I gotta
be honest with you once you start
buzzing your head it's kind of [ __ ]
awesome you know what it's great about
having a shaved head you're always ready
to go I got to tell you as much as I
would love to still have a full an out
of here I love the fact that I'm always
ready to go all I got to do is throw a
shirt on splash a little water on my
face and you have no [ __ ] idea that I
was laying in my sweat pants five
minutes earlier oh speaking of which I'm
just kidding I always make sure I get
ready you know there was this [ __ ]
person you know I went out you know I
took some pictures with people after the
show and the these [ __ ] people that
have like this [ __ ] guy comes up I
can already smell him all right and then
he goes to put his arm around me during
the [ __ ] picture and I'm telling you
like literally could make me peel off
the [ __ ] balls was how bad this guy's
body odor was and he's with other people
and they don't smell it's like why don't
you say something to him because I'm not
gonna say it okay you paid money to see
me right I gave you a show and then I
come out there and take a picture and
then I tell you you smell bad
I wouldn't do that to somebody but jesus
[ __ ] christ he was [ __ ] hilarious
about this person - i kept running into
him and this person just loved to tell a
story that somehow involved
you know lifting his arms up past his
[ __ ] shoulders jaysus [ __ ] man I
never noticed how much you lift your
arms during telling a story until I ran
into this this guy [ __ ] wreaked
[ __ ] reet just completely [ __ ]
unacceptable well into his [ __ ] 20s
and he's standing he's got a couple of
friends with them who don't reek oh okay
you know wish I bad I wish any one of
those old-school [ __ ] you know the
spray-on deodorant and as he was telling
this story I mean like yeah and just
holding my nose and I would just spray
under one armpit no keeps telling this
story and then spraying under the other
one and then I just hand him the can do
the math there [ __ ] oh all right psycho
girlfriend all right psycho girlfriend
where am i okay so my girlfriend and I
have been together for about five years
and lately I've been feeling the get
engaged pressure from her family well
yeah I'm 23 and she's 21 all right let
me rephrase that well no I thought you
guys were older oh we've been together
since high school
and I haven't experienced much else
besides of course the young middle
school tug job girlfriends I'm afraid of
some day regretting missing out on
meeting a ton of different girls like
all my buddies happen I mean you're only
young once right
my girlfriend flips out on me about
watching porn because I'm thinking about
other girls and she acts like I'm
cheating on her and half of the time
when we're out she thinks I'm checking
out other girls cuz you probably are
dude because you want to because you
want to break up with her I was what I'm
guessing she's a drop-dead gorgeous girl
so I don't get what she's so insecure
about but like I said she's crazy she
gets abusive with me and I just kind of
sit there and take it all the time she's
latina by the way Honduran and
Nicaraguan she's got that wild temper
all right now was that considered racist
to say that latina chicks
or a little crazier than what unlike
what pasty drunken Irish chicks oh yeah
they're always so even keeled when I
asked for space I woke up the next day
and my car was keyed she claims she had
nothing to do with it I love the girl
she's all I've ever known and she's
amazing most of the time but I'm not
sure if I can live like this forever
with their temper and her jealousy what
would you do anyways love the podcast
thanks for the advice and go [ __ ]
yourself PS good luck with the home gym
everybody knows you got no business in a
regular I'll go [ __ ] yourself like a no
business in a regular gym oh and you do
what you're sitting here and you're a
[ __ ] goddamn you know something I
actually had [ __ ] I actually had
sympathy boy I was gonna give you some
good advice you know what go [ __ ]
yourself you know what your problem is
in this thing
you you know you just allowed it you're
young I'm not gonna be a dick to you
okay cuz you young this is the deal
alright you got yourself a hot girl
alright and you didn't know how to set
up the relationship she [ __ ] rolled
all over your ass see what I do in your
situation if I was 23 I'd be doing what
you were doing I'd be staying in the
relationship wanting to get out and
dealing with this [ __ ] but I can
tell you this right now her looks aren't
always gonna be there but she's always
gonna have keys you know what I mean so
that's what you're signing up for the
looks go out the [ __ ] window
you're marrying the [ __ ] person that
this [ __ ] lunatic every time you know
god forbid your mailman is a [ __ ]
woman who's younger than her at that
point you know I don't know I don't know
I can use two wishy-washy I can't tell
whether you [ __ ] want to be in it or
not but I can tell you this right now
any woman Keys your car that's it it's
[ __ ] over okay that is a love being a
complete [ __ ] psycho a complete
disrespect for your own property and a
sign that when she was a child she was
never told no the fact that you would go
out and do something like
yeah I don't know it sounds to me like
you want to go [ __ ] and get some notches
on your belt and you're afraid that if
you do and you break up with this girl
that she's gonna [ __ ] stab you I
don't know
I got claustrophobic reading it if that
means anything but I'm a [ __ ] lunatic
alright sketchy ex-girlfriend
hey you [ __ ] a leprechaun Jesus
everybody's staring into the redhead
[ __ ] this week every every once a while
I got to give you guys [ __ ] okay can you
be a little more original
I like that Billy blank ball that was
[ __ ] funny
58 [ __ ] you know [ __ ] redhead
jokes in a row I get it you know I get
it you don't have an hour's time you can
do with 10 minutes set your a showcase
comic all right hey you [ __ ] you
leprechaun I am 16 years old and my
girlfriend is 15
today she texts me she texted me with a
picture of a tattoo asking if I liked it
it is what it is the date of her
grandfather's death personally I hate
tattoos and thinks if she keeps getting
them she would look like a [ __ ] phone
book I also think her mother is
irresponsible spelt with a bunch of E's
irresponsible for letting her get a
tattoo spelt with one oh so young what
are your thoughts about this and how how
what's your thoughts about this and how
she didn't tell me till after she got it
thank you
and I love your shows in your podcast
yeah all right
she's 15 she already got her first
tattoo what you got to do is close your
eyes and age her when is she getting the
face tattoo and the nose ring in the
[ __ ] Olympic [ __ ] rings in her
ears to be different yeah I'm not into
tattoos you know I think a certain type
of person can pull it off
and that's not 98% of the population but
98% of the population for some reason
has tattoos now I don't get it I feel
like there's a certain level badass dude
in a certain level badass chick that
gets tattoos and when you meet him it
makes sense and it actually you know I
don't know if I see a woman and she's a
badass and she has tattoos it actually
makes her more attractive to me if she's
just some [ __ ] dope you know and she
has like some advice column tattooed on
the back of her [ __ ] neck or some
Chinese sign above her ass crack
you know symbol then yeah it's just like
that Jesus Christ you know like the
amount of people out there that gets
sleeves like back in the day when you
got his sleeve I mean you are like some
biker outlaw you know now it's like you
work at Urban Outfitters you know and
you the biggest badass thing about you
is your [ __ ] music selection on your
[ __ ] iPhone I have no idea all I know
is I got to get a rental car in ten
minutes if I don't I'm gonna be late to
my show so this is the podcast for this
week the monday morning podcast god
bless all you I love when you guys
trashed me in the [ __ ] emails but
yeah can we can we just keep fighting
can you keep it interesting for the
reader here I know I'm a redhead I know
they're easy jokes but come on what if I
did that with my stand-up act you know
would you come out and see me if I was
out there go on wants to deal with New
York or no all right go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday
see